this panel is an excellent example of
the summers institute in
interdisciplinary focus the topic is
computational and statistical tools to
control a pandemic at this moment covert
19 needs no introduction
tragically more than 280,000 people have
died from this disease and by some
estimates more than 40% of the world's
populations been subject to some kind of
stay at home order which has led to a
huge economic and social cost also as
governments struggle to bring it under
control we've gathered a group of
experts today to discuss computational
and statistical tools and how they might
help in modeling and predicting the
pandemics progress in forecasting the
impact of public policy responses and in
making choices about those responses so
our distinguished panelists mother
Martha from the University of Virginia
Classica van Huston from the University
of British Columbia
uncle Moitra from MIT Shai Shelly
Schwartz from the Hebrew University of
Jerusalem and Intel Mobileye Anil Lully
Conti from the University of Virginia
and Ben Yu from UC Berkeley so the
schedule is over the next 45 minutes
we'll hear a short presentation from
each of the panelists then we'll have a
discussion between the panelists and
finally they'll respond to questions
from the audience so please type your
questions any time using that Q&A
feature on the resume screen and if your
questions addressed to a specific person
feel free to identify the panelists and
the panel we'll try to address as many
of these as we can so let me introduce
the first of our panelists murder of
Martha is at the University of Virginia
where is a distinguished professor in
bio complexity director of the Network
System science and advanced computing
division and professor of computer
science he is a passionate advocate and
practitioner of transdisciplinary team
science his areas of expertise a
computational epidemiology Network
science artificial intelligence
high-performance computing and data
analytics and over the last 20 years his
division supported federal authorities
in their effort to combat epidemics in
real time including the h1n1 pandemic in
2009 and the Ebola outbreak in 2014
welcome madam
you're on meat so thanks can you hear me
now yeah you can see the slides I take
and put it on slideshow great thank you
so much Peter and Christine I've never
been to the Simon Institute panel before
so this is a great opportunity
I appreciate it's a great panel so I'll
take about seven minutes
that's the allocated time and talk about
the work you're doing I want to thank
our team this is not my work by any
stretch of imagination it's it's really
the work of an entire group of folks and
and funds from various agencies and I
feel is among them I've put in some
references I understand it slides and
recording will be available so what a
call-out and so the papers we have
written as well as tutorials and such
we just got as a matter of serendipity a
big MSF expeditions grant on
computational epidemiology that I at
least want to let people know so
hopefully we'll be able to continue this
work and a little an anchor and I'm
Harlan who was unable to join they're
all part of that team so I'll give a
quick one-minute tutorial on Cove in
nineteen Peter said it correctly nobody
needs to know too much more about
general ideas but I think the key aspect
here is why we from a modeling
perspective feel that this became a
pandemic one is it's a notic disease so
everybody is in theory susceptible it
started in a dense urban region of China
which makes things easy to spread and
this particular disease has some
interesting characteristics one of which
is silent spreaders people are
asymptomatic they don't know about it
but they can spread the disease and
people can be infectious before being
symptomatic as well finally it's a small
world phenomena China is very well
connected to the world and as a result
it led to a rapid in a fast rate across
the world
no pharmaceutical interventions are
there yet I think we're at least six to
nine months away depending on how the
vaccine trials go
which makes it
challenging and really the only tool we
have at our disposal is social
distancing to control the disease given
that it's a theoretical talk I want to
give you a few simple pictures I'm not
going to go into details but I think
it's important to tell you how our group
has approached this particular work from
modeling standpoint we use a term called
network the PDA ology so the basic idea
is to build a digital twin of a city and
then and work with networks that span
the city and use that for a rapid emic
diffusion understanding so in a very
simple form here's a simple example of a
network where their nodes and edges have
marked them as susceptible or in
infectious infected or recovered nodes
as you will come through the edge
numbers represent the probability of
transmission and the way this disease
gets moving through the through the
network the dynamics is very simple
model it's called independent cascade
model the red node tries to
independently infect its neighbors and
it's successful if the coin toss comes
out to be on the right side and in this
particular example from t0 t1 it was
able to infect v1 v2 could not in fact
be three and it recovers then in the
next step we won and v2 recovered but
infected before and we we six and then
we have the last step in which the last
node were infected so this really gives
you the understanding of dynamics and
that's all from a mathematical
standpoint the model needs to know
modular needs to understand and then the
problems become interesting for all
sorts of reasons I'll tell you so what
it does is it gives you a very large
Markov chain and I've given you a very
small fragment of the chain it's it's
like a configuration graph for Turing
machines the node in in the middle there
in colors is a the configuration of that
edge of the node States and then you
have a arrow between two of these super
nodes if you want to call it that and
tells you the probability of moving from
one so so super node in the Markov chain
to the next the problem really is that
these markov chains are exponentially
larger than the old graph itself and
that's what makes the problem hard to
solve
we have results and others are results
that show this hardness in a very
concrete manner so the kinds of
questions that our group has been
studying now for this particular
pandemic but even before during the
Ebola pandemic as well and h1n1 things
like risk of importation projection of
demand and the healthcare system
counterfactual analysis economic impact
resource allocation forecasting the
course and we have developed a number of
different apps one of them is a covert
surveillance dashboard that has been
quite popular we're also developing
another app with the Stanford group
which is a part of the expedition's
project Michael Bernstein needs it to
collect the various policies that have
been put put in place in the u.s. at the
county level to slow down the virus so
I'll take just one example in the
remaining time I have to show you how
interesting and rich this problem area
is and I've focused on social distancing
because the central problem and here are
the elements of what the social
distancing problem might look like there
are various measures of effectiveness
there is strategic worse and worse there
was the social behavior this questions
are to fairness and privacy there
questions led to offline versus online
algorithms and coevolving algorithms and
then questions say to information that
could be complete partial perfect and
finally I think the hardest part as a
modeler that I want to let people know
is all models project something based on
some understanding and you can read and
hear about an amazing amount of debate
on how good these models are I don't
think I can answer this in 20 seconds
but we can have a discussion later on
but it's an important part so in in in a
very simple abstract form what you are
given is a social network
pardon my mistake in the first line and
what you want to do is to do social
distancing that reduces the epidemic to
at the extent possible but minimizing
the social impact and I have tried to
outline a few measures of effectiveness
such as number of hospitalizations
number of deaths number of new new
infections and on the economic and
social side I have talked about loss in
revenue and
so let me show you through pictures how
social distancing might look like right
and I've just taken one part of the
eight boxes that I showed you earlier
which is a who why and what so in this
example here we decide in three
different ways to to do social distance
in the first is by closing work the
second is by isolating folks who are
infected and third was quarantine these
folks got closer in some form in social
interaction form to people who were
infected and were asked to quarantine
such as the folks on say diamond
princess ship here second part of this
puzzle which is when do you start the in
the social distancing and when do you
end it in this particular case if you
decide to do what's called test trace
and isolate then you might say okay I
tested the nodes shown in the dotted box
and I found they're worse they were
infected so I'm going to isolate them
and I'm gonna ask them to stay at home
for 14 days or more depending on what
the protocol is and here is a more
interesting one the pulsing strategy
right everybody agrees that you cannot
shut the society on for all the time so
this is a simple cartoon that shows you
that used oh close the work for some
time then open it at some point again
close it if the numbers go up and again
open it and on and on it goes till you
reach a certain level of epidemic spread
in the community that it's not deemed
very harmful to open your society again
so like let me just summarize of how we
would do in practice as a theoretician
for longest time this was very cool to
me i could study these problems in
abstract but I what I find as I do this
in practices if you want to study this
building this network is the challenging
part you know big challenges to how how
do you build a network in the first
place once you're given the network the
problems are still hard but at least
they're well-defined so the way we have
done this over the last 15-20 years is
you build digital twins of cities you
take a city we build out the
representation of the city and its
inhabitants in a manner that is
statistically very close to how the city
would look like and this is the endless
process you can keep improving it we
then build simulations
agent-based models or network models if
you want to call it to study how
diseases would spread and then build
epidemiological workflows that use
simulations in the black box along with
other tools in machine learning and AI
to do calibration forecasting resource
allocation and other problems so I'll
stop here we can in the interest of time
Peter and then let others speak and we
can take questions then thank you
wonderful thank you mother
so just a reminder we'll save the
questions to the end so if you have
questions use the Q&A feature at the
bottom of your zum-zum screen so our
next speaker is class Govan Huston she's
at the University of British Columbia in
Vancouver her research interests include
modeling prediction and control with
applications in medical devices
mechatronics and robotics and lately
she's been working on a robust and
provably safe automated drug delivery
service for use in operating rooms a
drug delivery device I'm sorry he is an
operator and she's going to tell us
today about the role that control theory
has to play in public policy choices
Cosco yes thank you thank you very much
and thank you very much for this
opportunity to talk about our our work
the work that I did with in
collaboration with chemo and and Greg
Stewart on feedback control for
designing the policies for return to
normal and as a subtitle here I added
which characteristics need to be modeled
accurately to make good decisions which
I think really is key here if you go to
the next slide please
so these kind of graphs I think
everyone's become quite used to seeing
in the in the press and and everywhere
around there's huge uncertainty about
lots of things of this disease in this
pandemic and even really good models if
they try to predict what's going to
happen in the next few months you you
see huge uncertainty envelope so in this
graph here on the top these would be
reported infections with the median and
I think it's 25th 75th and then the 95
and 5 percentile on it so we see you Jen
will open in the bottom graph we see the
level of non-pharmaceutical
interventions which would be social
distancing at this
so I'm I live in Vancouver BC these are
so our work has been focused on the
local situation these are numbers
actually realistic numbers for BC we we
haven't seen very high infection numbers
and at the moment we're looking at less
than 50 cases a day for the last week
so even based on this model that was
estimating the impact of social
distancing measures here are the
projections for September just due to
the uncertainty in the reproductive
basic reproduction number of this
disease are anywhere between say five
ten cases day up to well over a hundred
so that leads to a very large range of
possible case counts but are we really
going to wait until September to act if
we see that by July there are ten time
more cases than we have now
so I would hope not so from this
perspective as a control engineer we saw
that already all policy and and what
governments are doing they are using
feedback they are looking at case counts
they are looking at hospital occupancy
rates so nad confinement policy will use
feedback so if you could go to the next
slide please
if you know you know that you're going
to use feedback and you use this in
making predictions saying well now if in
two weeks the case count goes up a lot
I'm going to have to change the policies
that we have or hopefully fine-tune
rather than then really change them if
we take this into account in our
predictions and we see here on the right
site that to be able to mitigate this
huge spread in incase counts that we
would see by September you actually need
very little difference in the level of
non-pharmaceutical interventions and
this really is what feedback does
feedback naturally reduces the effect of
uncertainty and so incorporating
feedback into the models first of all
probably make more useful projections
than some of the projections but I've
been seeing in the press it reduces the
impact of model uncertainty on these
projections but also on
actually happens in the disease and it
permits the analysis of different
scenarios and just looking at this
specific example here one could wonder
how accurate you really need to estimate
this R naught which is the basic
reproduction number of the disease for
for decision-making so if you go to the
next slide please
what we do know from control theory is
that on the other hand what you measure
and with what delay really does make a
huge difference so here we we looked at
two different scenarios with on the left
the assumption that we can measure new
infection is relatively quick within six
days or actually after exactly six days
and on the right side we assume that we
can only measure measure symptomatic
patients with a 14 day delay of the
onset of symptoms which would be
somewhat similar to admittance to act to
the ICU and then we simulate the
appearance of new cases in our BC
population which would be due to travel
or whatever restrictions would be lifted
at that point so if you measure later
and you measure later in the disease
progression you get a later and a slower
response and you're obviously going to
see longer periods and a higher number
of cases and control theory has a lot of
tools available for analysis and also
tools that tell you what the fundamental
limitations are of what you can actually
achieve in certain situations so if you
could go to the next slide please so
from our perspective and this is the
reason that why we wrote an article that
was recently published in I Triple E
Spectrum this pandemic is characterized
by unstable growth new infections that
are only visible with a delay and very
many factors that are unknown so so huge
uncertainties and and therefore we hear
everywhere that this is going to be very
difficult to control process control
engineers frequently deal with delayed
and uncertain systems and they also less
frequently deal with unstable system
exothermic reactors nuclear reactors and
these all function safely on a daily
basis and as I said any policy update is
going to use feedback which which is a
good thing because feedback reduces the
effect
uncertainty and it is inherently robust
what control Theory offers on top of
that is systematic tools for analysis
and systematic tools for policy design
and we can think about optimizing
multiple interventions using multiple
input multiple output tools optimizing
the trade-off between the health
considerations and stability of the
pandemic and economic considerations and
what I find very interesting and what
I've seen and what I what I've seen
appear in the literature is this kind of
theory allows you to change the
perspective from saying well now what if
we relaxed policy a and we allow people
to do something again what's going to
happen you can change that to asking
well what if we want to achieve a stable
pandemic with this type of economic
considerations what do we actually need
to do to be able to achieve that and
what are not what are our options and
what are our trade-offs so that's what
our work has been about and I'm yeah we
feel that controls here we could
hopefully add a little bit to this and I
think the point is that normally luckily
we haven't ever been in a situation
where this was needed but unfortunately
that's maybe not the case at this point
fantastic thanks Fusco fascinating
perspective our next panelist is an
kumara Unger is at MIT he's completed
his MS and PhD degrees from MA MIT in
computer science
his research spans of diverse set of
topics from statistical inference to
optimization from approximation to codes
and combinatorics he's particularly
interested in algorithmic problems with
applications in machine learning and big
data and he's part of the NSF
expeditions project on computational
epidemiology that might have mentioned
welcome oh cool great thanks for having
me happy to join this panel so as Peter
mentioned so I'm at MIT I'm a
mathematician and a theoretical computer
scientist and I haven't been thinking
about these questions for very long but
very
happy that Mon devanne anil brought me
into their grant to start thinking about
these things it's a little disappointing
how pert ndon relevant they are these
days but such as life so I want to tell
you my own bias takes on you know some
of the models that are in the news and
you know how I think about them as a
theoretical computer scientist so we
have you know simple models that are in
the news like the SI R model which are
really just ordinary differential
equations based on very simple dynamics
about how the population mixes so you
have some number of people who are
susceptible some number or infected some
number who are recovered and you can
have more complicated models that are
embellishments of this and each pair
interacts and there's some chance that
you're going to create a new infection
this way and there's some rate of
recovery and of course you can all do
all kinds of fancier things with these
simple OTE models like you have natural
extensions like multi risk models or
things like the infection hospitality
and fatality rates might vary depending
on the groups that's particularly
relevant for things like kovat 19:00
where there appears to be huge variance
depending on different members of
population who's more vulnerable than
others now one of the things that I want
to mention qualitatively about these
models is that I think it's good to
approach these models not as black boxes
but with an appreciation for what kinds
of assumptions go into them and you know
in what sense these assumptions are
reasonable for what portions of the
curve and for which parts they're not so
if you think about these simple models
for you know the population mixing
randomly then they can tell you things
like early on in the curve you really
will get this exponential growth but you
can see that actually the curve decays
very quickly which is just not something
that we're seeing with real Cova data
because how actually people mix within
the real population depends on this
distribution of you know who's actually
going out when states are opened up how
much are people doing it so we're seeing
things which are you know have much
heavier tail you can still get some
basic understanding of you know what
fraction of the population needs to be
infected in order to have this kind of
herd immunity but I'm not sure I get too
much more from these simple models in
that now you can have more complicated
models like the AI hme model that's in
the news because
it's one of the main things that the
white house talks about when they make
policy predictions now this is
unidentified confidence intervals and I
do think you should take a lot of these
things with some grains of salt so in
fact what I posted here was a picture I
took from kovat projections calm which
actually shows the many different eye
hme models and how they varied over time
this is actually for their mean and
their confidence and rolls are actually
quite why now the other end of the
spectrum there's another famous model
and news which is the Imperial College
model just based on multi-agent dynamics
so you want to get some idea of how
agents are interacting you know are they
using public transportation how long are
they on it how long are they commuting
and they guess this based on some type
of census data and they estimate disease
dynamics per individual and then this
gives them a way to test out the
efficacy of different kinds of
interventions but the other thing which
i think is worth you know thinking about
in these context is that these are
extremely complicated models so they
have huge numbers of parameters so
whenever I see models with a huge number
of parameters I often wonder you know
how sensitive are the predictions that
they're making and actually are they're
much more parsimonious models that might
do the trick instead so we do really
need all of those different parameters
or there's some rough dynamics that
better explain what these models are
actually doing actually the Imperial
college model is quite interesting
because it wasn't open
to the public until pretty recently
through collaborations Microsoft and it
actually has some interesting issues I
spent a few nights ago on some of the
reddit coding forums because people had
documented all of these issues about how
it's not actually deterministic in its
predictions even if you fix the random
the seed in the random number generator
and it's not so clear whether it's an
issue that only arises in multi-threaded
implications of it or actually shows up
in single threaded so I think time will
tell but it was originally created from
a 15,000 line single source file which
was edited for over ten years so it's
really not so clear what's going on so
we have a lot of models but you know
something I want to think about is you
know qualitatively what are we getting
out of the models and what should we
expect to get out of the models because
the truth is I think we put a little bit
too much emphasis right now on how
accurate they are at predicting
individual numbers like you know the ICU
utilization and things like this but I
think there are really other types of
questions we can formulate where we
could get more leverage so what I mean
by this is that you know if you think
about these models not all prediction
problems are very easy these are just
fantastically difficult problems they're
very complicated ones they depend a lot
on multi-agent dynamics and psychology
but really the inputs these models are
things that we don't genuinely
understand yet we don't understand
things like the growth rate so when you
think about are not the rate at which
these infections are growing well
actually the CDC recently revised their
estimates from two point two to five
point five so that should give you an
idea about you know how much the
predictions these models can swing when
you change the input parameters in
values like this we also don't
understand things like the mortality
rate we don't understand things like the
fraction of the people who get it who
are asymptomatic we don't even genuinely
understand the antibody tests to a
certain extent because the bias is in
the sampling process now the point that
I wanted to make was maybe the only
truth is we should really be trying to
get out of these models at least in this
state of affairs where we don't
understand what these inputs should be
to these models are things which are
somehow robust so we need open source
models and we need some way to actually
test the
robustness of these predictions to make
sure that we're not making overly
confident predictions which just can't
possibly be that confident so you know
when you think about the predictions of
things like the eye hme model they have
very wide confidence intervals and if
you try out two different intervention
strategies and plug them into you know
models like that the companies that are
roles are so wide that you can't
necessarily tell which strategy is
better than the others but maybe if
instead of it putting the emphasis on
actually predicting how effective these
strategies are in terms of how many
deaths we have we can do things like
pairwise comparisons and understand
whether there's some ways that some
strategies dominate others in our
purrito you can also take different
perspectives from things like robust
optimization instead of focusing on the
all-important thing like the confidence
interval maybe we could think about the
parameters that we really don't
understand
should we try and minimize the
worst-case losses over that uncertainty
set of our of our parameters this would
be something that you do within robust
optimization it's an interesting
discussion I have about whether this is
the right thing or not to do here and
you know a lot of our understanding of
you know what fraction of people in
Santa Clara for example have antibodies
to co vid 19 well it's not so clear how
to interpret a lot of these studies
because of the biased way that they get
data so we don't understand things like
how suboptimal are the policies that
were implementing because they're based
on these kinds of incomplete information
that we don't actually know how
pervasive it is we could also ask things
like how much do we need to learn about
the state of the system in order for
targeted interventions to be effective
or how effective does tracing have to be
in order to actually partially open up
some of our economies so I'll stop there
and see the rest of my time and have
more discussions during the QA but
thanks thanks
so our next panelist is Shai Shelly
Schwartz Shai as a senior fellow at
Intel and CTO of Intel's mobile I and
professor in the faculty of computer
science and engineering at the Hebrew
University of Jerusalem his research is
on the theoretical foundations of
machine learning or not
algorithms and on mathematical models of
safety he's received several best paper
Awards and in 2016 was ranked 17th in
the market top 100 most influential
people in Israel and more recently has
served on an Israeli committee providing
advice on managing the covert 19 crisis
welcome shown thank you thank you Peter
let me show you the screen right so this
is a work with say a mantra Shulman was
approached by the Prime Minister of
Israel to help advising what strategy
should Israel adapt in order to fight
the copied nineteen and Emma come first
on some questions of what are the
properties of a good mitigated the
policy for managing the virus so there
are several considerations to assess
first and foremost how many people will
die from the virus how many how many
people will die is not an easy question
because if you just count someone that
died and had the virus it doesn't
necessarily mean that you guys from the
virus may be maybe yes maybe no so you
can also compare to the annual average
of death is in in the country and see
what is the difference another
consideration is will the health care
system collapse how many people will be
severely ill is a policy practical in
terms of available resources for how
long will the policy be sustainable and
what is economical and social price of
the chosen policy so focusing just on
one question is not enough we need to
address all of them some policies that
countries adopted do nothing adopt some
levels of social distancing precision
quarantine really find the positive
cases and suspect using contact tracing
technologists
to full lockdown and many countries the
chose policies and switched policies
over time not always for the right
reasons what I'm going to propose here
is what we advise to to the Israeli
government is a release based resource
allocation approach before I go into the
details of our specific proposal we
would like to discuss some of the
computational tools for analyzing the
policy so I will do it briefly because
some of the topics were already
mentioned and then I will went on to
describe our approach so I will touch
three tools the two of them are really
very very basic tools in in probability
and statistics the law of total
probability and conditional probability
concentration bounds and the last one is
compartmental models like the SAR that
has already been mentioned um so the law
of total probability is really one of
one of the most basic laws in
probability and it makes also a lot of
sense if you have two events a and B
then probability that a will happen
equals to the probability that a and B
will happen plus the probability that a
will happen and we will not happen very
simple and trivial another another
concept is conditional probability the
probability that a and B will both
happen is the probability that B will
happen times the probability that a will
happen given that B happened why are
these tools even though they are very
basic or important they can help us in
many ways and here is a very simple
example how to estimate the prevalence
of the virus so suppose that is the
event that someone has someone died from
Corona and B is the event that someone
is in
by Corona and what we would like to
estimate is a prevalence of Corona which
is a probability of being of the envy
over the population of interest then
using the two laws and the simple fact
that you cannot die from Corona without
being infected you can get that the
probability to die from Corona equals to
the probability to be infected times the
probability to die given that you have
been infected so if you can estimate the
probability of death by counting the
number of coroner death over the
population this will be roughly the
probability of the event a and according
to the Equality to it equals to the
probability of B times probability of a
given B so once once you know an
estimate of the probability to die from
corona given that you have been infected
you can now you can now monitor the
prevalence by monitoring the number of
deaths of course those are subtlety
there is a time lag etc etc but this is
just an example of how basic laws in
probability help to monitor the status
which is which is extremely important in
order to understand how your policy is
behaving over time and to make
adjustments accordingly the second tool
is concentration bounds
suppose we flip a coin and times and it
falls K times on its head what can we
say about the probability that the coin
will follow on its head so we want to
say that it will be K over N but this is
not entirely true it actually can be any
number between 0 and 1 and concentration
bounce tells you lower bound and upper
bound on the real probability of hand by
relying on K N and the confidence that
you are willing to take so the third
tool is a
compartmental epidemic models and it was
already mentioned so I will I will skip
this and just show the graphs that we
all like to see and what you see here is
the percentage of susceptible over the
population exposed infected and
recovered and flatten the the popular
term flattening the curves mean that the
the curves of the infected has a bell
shape and if it is a sharp curve and it
is bad because it means that you will
have many people infected at the same
time which can make the health system
collapse while if the curve is bored
flat then at a peak you will have less a
smaller number of of infected people and
then the health system can I can deal
with it
the these are based on the so called
basic reproduction number and as I
mentioned it affects both the number of
infected person at the peak as a
function of say a basic reproduction
number as well as the total number that
will have the the disease and will
recover either by being good again or
they will die or they will just stop
infecting others okay so these are three
really basic tools for analyzing a
suggested policy I'm going to present in
the real time that I left that is left
is our approach which is which place to
resource allocation so the basic
motivation is that it was mentioned
before and it is well known this disease
is mild for one group of the population
and ferocious for the other group
basically old people with certain
comorbidities are much more likely to
die and be
ille from the disease then young people
without without comorbidities and what
we what we found out based on analyzing
Israeli data is that the mortality rate
is between 100 to 200 times larger in
the high-risk group relatively to the
low-risk group
so what can we do with this observation
the immediate conclusion in our opinion
that you want to focus your attention to
protect the vulnerable questions is how
to do this so the idea is very simple we
want three levels of social distancing
mild social distancing among among the
lowest group this can prevent economic
collapse and and relied on abundant
resource of like washing your hands and
stuff like that then the second level of
social distancing is to have reasonable
but stricter social distancing among the
people in the high school but the most
important thing is to have a very strict
social distancing between the high and
low risk group in order to prevent
people from the lowest group to infect
people for the high risk pool how
practically to do this simply we need to
protect the vulnerable so some ideas how
to do this first you want to protect a
nursing homes these accounts in Israel
for roughly half of the death and also
up elsewhere in the world the government
can issue special ID to high-risk
members that will entitle them to
special consideration people of the
high-risk group would be entitled to
work from home or receive the payment
from from the state and you want the
resources of karana tests and the like
to focus on monitoring the number of
infected in the Hollis group and adopt
the level of social distancing between
the high and low
cooked accordingly so these are the
basic ideas of the policy how can we
analyze it so to analyze it we adapted
the sei our model to have two
populations there are eight compartments
for for the low rest and for for the
high risk and instead of one basic
reproduction number you want four basic
reproduction numbers to monitor the
level of infection between members of
the low-risk group and themselves member
of the low to the high and high to the
low and I will skip how we estimated the
ratio between the low and high let me go
directly to to the analysis so the idea
is that you want the curves to look like
this there are two curves these are the
number of infected people in the lowest
group and in the high-risk group so you
want much more people in the low-risk
group to be infected relatively to the
high-risk group but if you will adjust
it to the probability of being severely
ill need ICU and death as you want them
to be roughly sustained because the
probability to be severely ill is much
higher in the Harris group you can allow
much more people to be infected in the
low-risk group so just to to wrap up the
basic message that that we're trying to
say that we need to focus all the
attention and they're expensive
resources on the vulnerable and for
Israeli data analysis show that or at
least predict that the health system
would not collapse and the good question
is how to monitor it properly in order
to make sure that it's clear that our
models are wrong but that they are not
too wrong when they are robust to the
reality and I will stop here
wonderful thanks joy so our next speaker
is Anil Lula Conti Anil is a professor
in the department of computer science
and the bio complexity Institute at the
University of Virginia his research
interests are in the areas of
combinatorial optimization distributed
computing dynamical systems Network
science data mining and multi-agent
systems and in using algorithmic tools
from those areas to obtain rigorous
solutions for problems with immediate
social impact in epidemiology and public
health policy planning welcome Anil
thank you thanks for the opportunity to
speak here Peter
anything my screen
we can have great so I'd like to start
by acknowledging the large number of
collaborators with whom I have had the
great pleasure to work over the years so
we've already heard a lot about
different kinds of models being used and
the issues and what you can take away
from there
some of these models are really complex
they may involve complex workflows going
from data filling in the gaps doing
logical simulations and so on I'm going
to speak primarily on the issues and
just using these models coming up with
good analysis solving them and then even
after you have like optimal solutions in
these models how can you get policy type
of insights from them so the different
kinds of models we've already seen their
components include like a contact
network or some mixing structure the
built environment like the road network
disease model parameters of various
kinds behaviors of people like level to
which they are complying with social
distancing for instance interventions
for instance whether or not schools are
closed or lockdown guidelines and
weather and so on and in the case of
network models the output can be like a
random sub graph of of infections from
which you can read out various other
quantities like the time series of
infections and so on so like in other
domains the first step in using such a
model is calibration and in the context
of epidemics
this means matching spatio-temporal
characteristics this turns out to be a
really
Challenge so like we want to match the
characteristics for the large scale and
for the entire US as well as for
different regions there's a huge
parameter space and data uncertainty
making this a really hard problem in
addition a new thing which comes from
epidemics in contrast with other
biological physical systems is behaviors
of people who co-evolved with the die
not with the dynamics they see the
spreading people are going to cut the
mixing so there is both endogenous
change in the behaviors and exogenous
change because interventions are put in
so once you have the model set up like
most analyses the kind like mother
mentioned they involve large
experimental designs because there's
uncertainty in the parameters initial
conditions and so on so very parameters
and these are stochastic simulations so
you need to have lot of runs to get good
estimates so if the computing resources
are limited then this leads to
interesting question of whether you can
reduce the number of samples to compute
the quantities of interest so for
instance
can you use some kind of incremental
computation to like take the results the
epidemic outcomes for one probability
value and estimate some other kind of
setting some quantities like let's say
the expected number of infections are
easy to compute with Monte Carlo
sampling but some quantities like the
probability of a big outbreak that's a
very vent and estimating that is useful
for like doing in it's not make impact
analysis or probabilities of like
specific kinds of chains of transmission
so coming up with new strategies for
very event estimation in such
models as useful and finally the we
usually think of the simulation and a
forward direction it's given the right
input that produces a distribution but
often we want to look at inverse
problems where you want a sample from
the space of outcomes when you have
specific constraints so let say you need
like 10% of the people being infected
and those are all interesting
computational and statistical challenges
we already heard about different kinds
of interventions even in a vanilla
setting like simple graphs and Vivi's
models they were extremely hard
approximation algorithms problems but if
you look at the practical aspects they
lead to very interesting and different
dimensions so first of all these are all
their multiple objectives so we need
multi criteria optimization algorithms
there are lots of uncertainties and all
the components and they grab the source
disease model parameters and so on so we
need robust algorithm even if you had
the full information and you found the
optimal solution like come to like what
kinds of edges to character what nodes
to X and I'd it's not immediately useful
because in real policies we can't target
node to register you would have to make
a more implementable solution may be for
instance formula is things at the level
of groups but even like figuring out the
right formulations is an interesting
question one would have to deal with
limited compliance within a group and
there are issues of individual versus
local good which requires its varying
game theoretic aspects and fairness so
let's say solve these complex models
how can one go to get
some insights into policy kinds of
question the first thing is the kinds of
interventions which are under
consideration they come from a much more
restricted space and hopefully
understanding of the model solutions can
give estimates on how far they are from
the optimum and when does one even need
to search for near optimal solutions
like is that an implementable solution
is reasonable maybe that's good enough
the model structure can give insights
into like the trade-off between
individual and social good and
characteristics of near optimal
solutions can be learned specifically
like features of nodes which are part of
solutions and that can help in
suggesting new kinds of interventions so
I'll end with this new class of problems
of healthcare resource allocation that's
another complexity and this transmission
happening within hospitals as well and
that makes it really hard to optimize
over these so I will stop with that and
the discussion later right thanks Anil
and finally the the last speaker is my
distinguished colleague Ben Yu who is
Chancellor's distinguished professor in
class of 1936 chair in the department's
of statistics and lecture engineering
and computer sciences at UC Berkeley and
former chair of statistics at UC
Berkeley Ben's research focuses on the
theory practice and an algorithm design
for statistical machine learning and
causal inference her groups engaged in
interdisciplinary research with
scientists from the areas of genomics
neuroscience and precision medicine and
she's going to tell us about her work on
predicting covert 19 severity for
medical resource allocation welcome
Vinnie thank you thank you for having me
Peter so my group traditionally work on
scientific machine learning I'll call a
lot of collaboration with newer
scientists genomics and precision
medicine and
and open D ramen so late March we
responded to a call for data science
expertise by responsible life with a new
nonprofit organization and at the time
there were lots of lots of media
coverage of the need for PPEs personal
protection equipment and our initial
goal was really to help to aid research
allocation with responsible life so this
is teamwork I was very proud of my team
led 12 my students jumped in and for
stocks and we have been working we're
closing responsible life and we'll also
work with other people at the other
universities so an overview said huge
amount of work went to data curation
basically public data we got one and
non-public data but mostly probably data
hospital level on county level most of
the models are at a state level and we
do county level short-term prediction
and predict demand and also we use a lot
of news sources to get to the data
source and also to validate partially
what we predict so the curation took two
team members like full-time for many
weeks and many other group is using our
data so we basically get gained access
to New York Times many many other
sources as listed here and data curation
and preparation was very important part
of what we do and we also have race
vectors demographics social mobility
data and the database is being updated
continuously and open with calls and all
the data and with a pretty friendly data
structure computer use and we got some
data from Sam
Scarpino from North Eastern on the
hospital I would like to acknowledge so
the forecasters basically we did a lot
of other things because in the beginning
for nonprofit we did everything could
call hospitals but our main job was to
forecast the account because the case is
very much related to the how many tests
were done different states and counties
we thought death counts a more reliable
and recently we also not a lot of and
the
poor Tim dance camp is the word cat and
it's also more related to the hospital
team and so we did a lot of if
acceleration in the end we end up
combining two models kind of both
interesting why is just a linear model
at the county level for each county we
do the past few days five days and to a
linear projection and the second model
expanded the shared County exponential
produced a little more sophisticated we
use cases in neighboring counties and
also neighboring County - I will also
use demographic and risk factor
information to have shared exponential
growth model and then we took a bunch of
the model we divided our lives for audio
prediction without other dynamic signals
and to dynamic way the two predictors so
if one model works better short-term we
give a mall weight otherwise we rely on
the other model and the Tony math slide
from my talk is really this weighting
using the past predictions through loss
function we actually we do that at the
log that's account scale we have a
tapering factor mu so that we don't
assault rendering we don't use all the
past performance but you know we use
something like point five for this
particular problem so here are some
results and we also develop prediction
interval based on conformal analysis
using some exchange ability between the
prediction errors in the last five days
say and we have pretty trustworthy
prediction intervals so we have here for
California counties Santa Clara Los
Angeles Monterey we have on to block a
the xalapa America where a lot of PPS
will be needed and also some of our
county now much has happened so what
kind of the prediction interval doesn't
really capture Sonoma County because not
much is going on but for the rest we did
pretty recently for seven days and we
also look at if you look at the worst
cases to two counties in New York City
and one from I think for now but this is
a file so what I'm showing you now are
the three counties have the fast-growing
a death counts so we have two countries
from Philadelphia Philadelphia County
and also Montgomery County next to
Philadelphia and also County Middlesex
County in Massachusetts which is now far
from Boston you can see that for the
prediction intervals we covered we claim
we aim at 83% confidence of prediction
coverage and we actually all average
achieve that and we have so few low 260
but we don't go down to below 60% since
we are providing like support to the
hospital like if we have supplied tissue
at the hospital we decide to go for very
simplistic interval index they sound -
counts so we look at to predict death
counts accumulative and a new desk count
and we do present at type of
thresholding and classify the hospitals
into three categories high severity
medium and low even though we only have
best prediction at the county level
which is imputed the hospital level test
counts by using the number of employees
which we have and proportion to that we
only have one validation for this
imputed s count that has two level which
you see yourself seems quite well
correlated and we try to get more data
which to add a hospital level data we
just talk to California Department
Public Health people maybe they can
share some Hospital level for us to
validate and we also build pretty nice
visualization what you see here is Los
Angeles and Bay Area the number
indicated severe very dark red and pink
medium and kind of green low and what
being flashed out as areas are actually
the predicting newly deaths and from
this you can easily see that non-sensory
small eyes kind of stabilizing and the
bay area we're getting better so this is
like a one-week prediction overtime from
today and up to five six days
we have an interactive map linked from
website called COBIT severity dot-com
and we have other links we're also
working with the Center for spatial data
science people and universe Chicago they
have a lot more traffic there to have
when they're dedicated to our results
and you can actually glide and to look
at different days for the future
prediction and since we primarily try to
support responder life down LAN were
some key member of responder life has
really mastermind this delivery which
happened last Friday to Temple
University Hospital 500 face shields so
we're also working with local face
makers like mask makers and to give them
material and with a donor so they have
some lots of jobs to produce his face
shoes and being shipped and responder
life is also building ourselves forces
of justice system for supply chain and
use our sorority index and this is
something also we like to get people
know hopefully other people take
advantage of that and Santa Clara has
also delivered the makers there to
Northern California hospitals and this
is really the delivery was Inc
collaborative ways get as PPE is a group
of medical residents IRA bridge the
pilots who just freely fly these
supplies and make her Nexus which in the
Bay Area
yeah and another synergy mill makerspace
in North Carolina
we're expecting half a million officios
manufacturing in Asia to be delivered
and we saw how did distribute in the US
and another half a million to the rest
of the world so the impact our work the
young responsible life actually our
website has been quite popular and at
least fifty some people groups have
unique loans to our website and some of
the final projects in Berkeley actually
using our data and working with us at
Chicago which is talking to California
State Department private house and we
have another project ongoing really try
to match different counties moving in
two hours I'll be at the causality and
we can actually match the performance
of this more like machine learning based
models using just through the time lag
and match different counties and hope
the future the more advanced counties
can inform the county of little lag
behind and to do predictions and we hope
to can trap a little further in seven
days using this matching methodology
space ongoing thank you fantastic thanks
Ben and thanks to all the panelists for
really excellent presentations and and
and really diverse let me get the
discussion started in in two related
directions and these reflect many of the
questions that have been posed by the
audience
and they're in questions of comparing
the different models and validating the
assumptions that go into them so we've
seen several types of epidemiological
models questions you know do we
understand when they make different
predictions and how to decide which
which to use so so for instance the the
simple compartmental models consider
just an average infection rate across
the population I I guess include honest
about those and shy told us about a
slightly more refined model that splits
the population into two groups
Madhavi even more refined things where
we we use properties of the graph of
interactions between people so so what
parameters of the disease or population
do we need to know to determine whether
this kind of fine-grained modeling
detail is is important and I guess for
two things as several of the panelists
have pointed out perhaps we're
interested in accurate models prepper
perhaps are interested just in effective
control of the pandemic and I guess the
related question is is validating the
assumptions that go into the approaches
that that we've heard about how do we
validate those assumptions and we know
that the approaches will work in
practice are there Diagnostics that can
be used along the way to verify that the
assumptions aren't too far from correct
or I guess perhaps just close enough for
the policy choices still to be effective
and and is there some way to quantify
the risks that are that are involved
quantify in advance the risks that are
involved
and result from the errors in our
assumptions or estimates as we follow
these different approaches so perhaps
include would you like to start us off
sure so I think you know I think it's
good to look for models that are complex
along the right dimensions so definitely
with something like Coppa 19 as far as
we can tell it really does spread in
different ways across different groups
of the population so I have two young
kids so of course you know one of the
first things I was looking through all
the news was to try and get an
understanding of how this is spreading
through kids through daycare is this
kind of thing and we were trying to
figure out lunch we could pull our kids
out of daycare but you know it really
does depend a lot on the fine-grained
dynamics so there are places in New York
City where they started trying to
offload some of the ICU bed utilization
by sending some of their elderly
patients to nursing homes and then you
have a difficulty that a lot of the
nursing home staff are not actually
prepared or trained and how to deal with
infectious diseases so that level of
dynamics really does affect how these
different diseases spread on a group by
group basis in different ways now I also
want to add one more thing which is that
there are tons of models that are out
there I think it's a time where we
should really only slip to trust models
which are actually open source and are
available or replicable because a lot of
the models are not and it's actually not
so good
we spent a bunch of time trying to
figure out what the heck was going into
the Imperial College model before it was
publicly released and we had no idea how
to create these fantastically
complicated multi-agent models so I
think you know the public really does
need to demand this so that we can
perform our own kinds of robustness
checks to understand you know how
reasonable are these assumptions to play
with things like what happens when the
parameters you're putting in are not
things which are completely confident
about because those are things that are
estimated from data too so you know what
happens to the prediction of the models
in these different spaces I'll I'll
leave it off to Maude of dance or some
more
in general the amount of uncertainty in
the lack of data is huge but I want to
make a few important points I think all
models the three classes the statistical
model that been talked about the Cir
side models and the network models have
their place and I think they're useful
in different context let me give you a
few interesting and useful examples
we've been doing before this event
happened we had been participating in
CDC sponsored iLife influenza challenge
there we have fair amount of data no for
going back last few years and
statistical models that are really based
on time series analysis did actually
quite well so Los Alamos model that if
you mentioned I believe uncle is based
on such a such a technique on the other
hand a Cir cell models have been very
effective in in other cases especially
in the early part of the of the system
largely for the computational simplicity
that they have you have better
understanding as you said unlike
sameen's model which was tough to
understand for many people but I think
the network models have their own place
as well I want to give you just one
example where I think the network style
model would actually be more insightful
than the other models and the example
that we have been using is the following
simple cartoon let's say ever Network
you know and I want to say that I want
to reduce a social distancing by 20%
now this question of 20% can be
operationalized in many many different
ways they essentially is one knob to
work within an ACI a model by
controlling beta you might control gamma
which is the infection time but really
beta is the one you would control for
him but that doesn't make make the
representation of this intervention very
good in a network you have a more
natural representation you can decide or
take 20% of the edges out you can thin
they just down by reducing the weights
on them and multiple other ways and this
actually came to for when a complete
lockdown happen when we in our models we
found out that when you have a
relatively complete lockdown that
happened in
many places in the world you effectively
have small networks which are household
networks and all other edges are
essentially gone in our modular
approximations that form of essentially
shattering the network would not be easy
to pick up in a Cir state model so
that's an example of where such a model
could be used now you don't have to
build a full complicated model you could
actually build these small templates of
networks and then a nice analysis of
balls and bins kind of argument so I
think the way I would like to close my
my part of the argument is that each of
them has a used model should be used for
structural understanding in in some ways
I think the desire by the public to come
up with precise predictions is way too
strong in this and the one thing that I
will mention and dr. Fauci said it very
well is if you probably did the right
thing today it would be viewed as an
overreaction in a few days because these
are Co evolving systems at the end of
the date they have almost quantum like
feature where your actions in the
modeling space of predicting something
either a doomsday style prediction or
not pretty you know will affect what
people do in terms of behaviors so I
think we need to remember this aspect in
in social systems and not view it as
perfect a dictor's that will likely come
out Peter that's all from my side for
now right
related question from the audience
I guess directed it a try in
differentiating mortality by high risk
versus low risk the asks you know what
happens if this simply produces a higher
mortality right for younger people you
know what about the possibility of
unintended consequences of this sort of
of this sort of approach so are there
are there diagnostic tools we can use to
to check on errors in our modeling
assumptions of this sort
some so first of course I think overall
with respect to models all the models
are wrong and some of them are useful so
I don't think that the models tell tell
us what will happen but they give us a
tool and the trend and one of the things
is to monitor prevalence in the young
population in the high population
adjusts the numbers of the mortality
rate of the ico cases what we do know
from this from the evidence so far in
this pandemic is that it's true that
there is an exponential growth but but
for example if you look down it's very
effective so if things are if you know
to monitor things correctly and you
catch them in time you have this tool of
full lockdown to to calm things down if
you if you are completely wrong so it's
very important to to monitor things all
the time now overall regarding what will
happen if we increase the level of of
death of death in the lowest population
so according to to our calculations at
least what we know so far is that
mortality rates in in the low-risk
population is not different than other
types of other reasons for this for
example car accidents so I think that
yes people will die
unfortunately and every death is very
sad but we do not lock down the country
because there are people that are dying
from car accidents so we need to keep
this in mind and at least give so if
someone is very afraid of the of the
virus it doesn't have to go out but the
the country needs to allow it the
freedom to choose for himself whether it
wants to take the risk in the same way
that he is taking the risk
when he is taking his car
go shopping and not working or not
taking the public transportation last
comment regarding uncertainties there
are many things that we don't know about
about this virus it's new and I think
that what the class talked about about
using tools from control theory is very
important it's not that we need to plan
out and then forget about everything and
stick to the plan for half a year or two
years or I don't know we can adjust
things and we should jot things all
sometimes and and some of you know that
that I come from from developing
self-driving cars
so when developing self-driving cars
there are a lot of uncertainties you
don't know maybe there is some road
users on pedestrian which is hiding
behind behind the car and is occluded
that you don't see him it's uncertainty
you don't know if the driver next to you
will decide suddenly to swerve into you
also uncertainty and there are two basic
tools to handle uncertainties in
controlling system in particular one of
them is that you all the time want to
rippln and you want to minimize the
delay between you're sensing between how
you sense the environment to the time
you make decisions so it's good to
change the decisions all the time if it
is for the right reasons the second
thing is that when you have
uncertainties one way which I think it's
coming from computer science perspective
you want to apply some worst-case
analysis you don't want to rely on
expectation you want worst case but you
want to be - you want to be cautious but
not paranoid
so you want to make some reasonable
assumption
and in this regard I would like to
mention what the CDC published about
whether you got the virus and then maybe
you are not immune it's true maybe or
not but if you are not in hearing then
there is no chance for vaccine and also
it's reasonable to assume that you will
be immune at least for some time so it's
it's an example of what I call a
reasonable assumption of course it may
be wrong and we will need to replan but
I think it's reasonable now to assume
that if you got the virus that you are
Indian given though we don't have
definite proof for that good Thanks
right so turning to some of the
questions from the audience there's one
here for Alaska about feedback control
and the question is might the use of
feedback require repeated closings and
closings and openings of economies
something politicians would be reluctant
to do so how do in designing these
policies how do we take account of those
those constraints that we can't be
making fine grained adjustments
constantly yeah so I saw a few questions
related to two similar things come up
and first of all any policy that will be
put in place will use feedback so any
limitation do two things that you cannot
measure accurately due to not wanting to
change the policy obviously every day
those limitations by saying we are going
to use feedback I am only emphasizing
that those limitations exist but if you
are going to have your politicians say
we open up now those same limitations
exist those are fundamental limitations
if you limit what you want to do with
changing policy for example let's say I
only want to change it every two or four
weeks that that puts limitations on what
you can achieve with what you can expect
to achieve with a policy like that so
from a control perspective if we know
that we have a very slow
response time we can't act very quickly
or we can't measure very quickly you
have to you have to move slowly yes
those are limitations and those are fun
that fundamental limitations and I think
there's very interesting work to do from
with with tools that we have in control
theory to to quantify some of those
which we haven't done at this point
a question for for bin and I I guess
potentially for several of our panelists
the question is we know that ensemble
models perform very well predictions and
forecasts can be at least as good as the
best performing model if not better yet
policymakers seem to rely on fragile and
not necessarily reproducible individual
models
what can computational and statistical
scientists or the institutions they
belong to do to make sure that high
quality work actually has an influence
on policy that's not an easy question
bin well my tape will be olestra we just
reach out to a California Department
public house we have to get engaged in
the FT biology community and then to see
whether they can use somewhere our
models one thing I talked to them this
morning was can we use the short term
pretty accurate prediction as a
constraint of some of them are empty
models and kind of combined take
advantage of both but I think there's a
lot of things we have to get the people
to trust us and to stingwell useful
before we have an impact and that's what
a lot of good politicking I think has to
happen for people this thing will be
useful because they think they are very
busy already why would they listen to
you so I think that's gonna be a
obstacle as a whole community to
convince them that were there and we can
help and were useful and then maybe some
RDS will enter how the decision-making
but I think the human connection is
probably the most important and whether
the statistical machine learning
community I really can either have a
console or them to work with and not be
the best and individually reach out to
them we just made a connection I'd be
working with stomp Ally for the last six
weeks we just made our first connection
with State Department no I can't phone
you Peter if I could just add a few
words if it's okay with you we have been
working with our state we are we provide
them the modeling support like Ben said
and as I said we also provide support to
multiple do you know agency
at the federal level Tod CDC and others
and I think what Ben said really is a
good point if you want to support them
then you've got to get embedded with
them in a mean deeper way because I
think the questions that come around and
I'm sure she has seen this too are much
more meaningful and and and that allows
you to to come up with abstractions that
are meaningful theoretically but also
come up with solutions that they can
finding go ahead and use this if you
make a spherical cow that doesn't help
them if you keep all the bells and
whistles they wanted then we can't do
much with it so I think working with
them very closely usually leads to a
good balance between the two sides all
right so one other question
so the the questioner points out that
these discussions have understandably
focused on covert 19 however how can
these tools and more generally computer
science be used to mitigate or stop the
next pathogen while it is still in
liftoff so I can see a little bit if you
want there are multiple programs in
place and I think we for all the
problematic situation that this virus
has if you look at the speed at which
the vaccine development is happening the
speed at which our surveillance systems
have come up and trying to tell us
something about it
it's remarkable actually now that
doesn't say anything about people who
have lost their loved ones but I think
things have improved I think there are
global surveillance systems much like
that was set up for tsunami you know for
earthquakes would actually and if it can
be funded for a period of time I think
in personal opinion these things come
they become fashionable and then they go
if you want to have something that is
going to last for a long time they need
to you know keep it funded so that
systems can be built and can be
maintained for a period of time and I
think that we are technologically
everything we need is is in place to a
large extent I think it
requires the will of the world to keep
it going
alright and one question about causal
inference which you mentioned in your in
your presentation been so there was a
recent New York Times headline that
described the current situation as the
trial-and-error reopening a country by
country and state by state experiment
with whole societies as test subjects
I guess we're seeing schools opening in
Denmark and restaurants opening in Hong
Kong and parks in Thailand you know all
kinds of random things going on it it
sounds like a very risky way to
experiment with people's lives and the
question is could there be a silver
lining
could this be useful being as a as a
causal inference expert is there
something to be gained from this
situation as a kind of natural
randomized controlled trial that we can
use for causal inference about the
impacts of various policy choices I
would like to hope so but I mean the
jury's still out but I think we should
definitely try to Stephanie we can try
to argue for a natural experiment so a
lot of the burden relies on how we're
gonna argue the case so we really start
- of the counties and I see it as more
like our holistic causal inference it's
now something which is plug into the
numbers and then come up with causal
conclusions but thinking along the
causal lying I think is really useful
but a lot of the assumptions that goes
into a causal models we have to get
experts in and something we might be
wrong but I think there's hope but a lot
depends on whether we have good matching
that's what I see it's happening can we
find two counties for example have
different policies and you can argue
that seems to be a random toss
not independent with the characteristics
and they match and other important
character Dharma graphics and you see
what happens that's what I'll be looking
for so I'm cautiously hopeful to have
useful things coming out of it
but I don't I wouldn't recommend pretty
like it has to be very qualitative
causing inference then trust the numbers
too much all right any others like to
address that okay one other theme that
appeared throughout the the Q&A was was
a question about spatial as well as
temporal evolution pointing out that a
lot of the models are that that we saw
where we're predicting how things
evolved through time and and the
question was about modeling the spatial
dimension also you know understanding
for instance the spatial spread so so
certainly you know I know these models
are sophisticated enough to do that
someone like to comment on on that sort
of issue perhaps O'Neal hey so yeah like
models depending on the scale that they
are considering can we have spatial
temporal aspect calibrating those is a
hard question and one thing which is
going to be useful and like just from
analyzing the incidence rates and
different places understanding when two
counties or groups of counties in wall
similarly and then diverge I think those
can give some useful insights but yeah
generally I think it's right now it's
still pretty hard
all right and and finally the last
thread that I spotted through the QA
were in the category of somehow ethical
questions so you know if we're thinking
about imposing thresholds this is high
risk this is low risk you know what
about the people who fall just below the
threshold what about thinking about
optimizing years of life saved versus
number of lives saved as a metric anyone
have an opinion that they would like to
express about these sorts of these sorts
of issues
that's a really tough question of course
that's my opinion
uh-huh I am I think that's a that's a
question that where the answer is also
going to depend on on the place and on
the on the community and on the politics
in the community and I think that what
we can do from computational theoretical
point of view is give these
decision-makers the tools that allow
them to make an important decision
keeping those ethical questions in mind
great that the communication would be
very very important whether we can
convey what the model does and can
cannot do so the communication with your
decision become really key very much so
I think that's a great point at which to
stop so a big thank you again to all of
our panelists who did a fantastic job
that was a really really fascinating and
an informative discussion you've given
us a lot to think about